man if you didn't know man I'm  everything no because my son is Mexican  so I'm Mexican my my um they say I'm  Nigerian because I got a little bit a  tiny tiny bit of African you know I'm  related to Francis and Izzy it shows you  know weiner  um the front of waist down yeah on the  waist down um  I got you know and you know that black  athleticism yeah I grew up around that  man these guys no I mean no disrespect  you guys are [ __ ] athletic bro so I  don't think that's disrespectful I'm a  little I'm a Caucasian I'm Indian I'm  African I'm Mexican you're a real mutt  yeah I'm a real mutt man I'm an American  oh there you go cheers way to finish  that off yeah I would have never I mean  if you gave me